fond de la forme en revenant sur les
mots et les images qui ont marqué
l'actualité
samedi à 23h45 sur public sénat
ravi de vous retrouver sur public sénat
dans un instant vous allez pouvoir
suivre l'examen en seconde lecture du
projet de loi qui crée un défenseur des
droits
hier les sénateurs ont rejeté
l'intégration du contrôleur général des
prisons dans cette autorité nouvelle que
va être le défenseur des droits autre
point de désaccord la nomination des
adjoints du défenseur des droits par le
premier ministre les sénateurs souhaité
que cette nomination soit soumise à un
avis du parlement
cette disposition n'a pas été entérinée
en séance cet après-midi la discussion
reprend à l'article 20 elle concerne les
pouvoirs du défenseur des droits
tout de suite donc direction l'hémicycle
du sénat très bonne après midi à tous
l'ordre du jour appelle la discussion
deuxième lecture du projet de loi
organique modifié par l'assemblée
nationale relatif au défenseur des
droits et du projet doit modifier par le
front national relatif au défenseur des
droits dans les discussions des articles
du projet de loi organique
nous sommes parvenus un article 20 au
sein du chapitre iii consacré aux
dispositions relatives aux pouvoirs du
défenseur des droits à l'article 20 j'ai
une demande de prise de parole qui tombe
un amendement 74
qui tombe un amendement 90 tenté par
roland courteau
merci monsieur le président très
rapidement il s'agit au vu de la
spécificité et de la technicité des
droits de l'enfant de rendre obligatoire
l'avis préalable du défenseur des
enfants sur l'opportunité d'une
intervention du défenseur des droits
cet amendement et je le précise la
reprise d'une proposition d'amendement
de l'unicef et du défenseur des enfants
son importance est donc manifeste
monsieur le président merci messieurs en
porter c'est pas que l'unicef avait le
droit d'amendement mais enfin on
découvre alors on va reprendre
l'argumentation qu'on a déjà développé
hier le défenseur des enfants est un des
adjoints du défenseur des droits
le défenseur des droits pourra lui
confier l'examen de certaines
réclamations mais il n'y a pas lieu
d'inscrire en loi organique un avis du
défenseur des enfants sur la
recevabilité des réclamations
donc avis défavorable très bien alors
monsieur le ministre
gouvernement
avis défavorable très bien y at il sur
cet amendement 90 les explications de
vote
je n'en vois pas je le mets aux voix qui
est pour
l'amendement présenté par roland
courteau qui est contre 2 3 5 6 7 7 à 7
tel amendement n'est pas adopté
deux albums en discussion commune un
amendement 46 qui est présenté toujours
par roland courteau
oui monsieur le président l'article 20
du projet de loi accorde au défenseur
des droits un pouvoir d'appréciation sur
les faits qui font l'objet d'une
réclamation qui lui sont signalés et qui
appellerait une intervention de sa part
la rédaction de cet article a évolué au
cours de la navette parlementaire dans
la rédaction proposée par le
gouvernement l'article 20 prévoyait que
le défenseur des droits n'est pas tenus
d'indiquer les motifs pour lesquels il
décide de ne pas donner suite à une
saisine le sénat en première lecture a
décidé que le défenseur doit au
contraire motivé ses réponses aux
personnes lui adressant des réclamations
il est en effet souhaitable que le
défenseur des droits puissent expliquer
à la personne le saisissant pourquoi il
ne donne pas suite à sa demande
les députés sont allés plus loin en
prévoyant que le défenseur des droits
doit également indiqué les démarches
entreprendre pour résoudre les problèmes
soulevés en deuxième lecture la
commission des lois du sénat a supprimé
cette dernière obligation estimant
qu'elles risqueraient je cite le
transformer le défenseur des droits en
un gigantesque bureau d'information
administratifs ce qui n'est pas sa
vocation constitutionnel fin de citation
nous entendons les préoccupations émises
par le rapporteur toutefois toutefois
nous estimons que la mission naturelle
du défenseur des droits consiste non
seulement à régler les difficultés
soulevées devant lui mais aussi a
indiqué le cas échéant
et si nécessaire à la personne dans la
saisine n'appelle pas son intervention
les démarches qu'il peut entreprendre ou
les organismes qu'il peut contacter pour
l'aider
à résoudre son problème c'est d'ailleurs
la pratique couramment suivi par les
autorités existantes alors que la loi ne
leur en fait pas obligation d'où notre
amendement monsieur le président merci
laurent discussion commune un amendement
il est présenté par la présidente laure
gratias merci monsieur président excusez
moi pour moi mon retard mais je crois
que on est dans une vie damman une
logique différente ça apparaît
maintenant très clairement et donc bien
sûr nos amendements sont immédiatement
contredit par la nouvelle logique de la
commission des lois la centralisation
que vous opérez que vous avez défendu
hier à plusieurs reprises au tour du
défenseur des droits est évidemment
d'autant plus préoccupante pour nous et
d'autres qu'elle touche à des domaines
aussi délicat que la lutte contre les
discriminations la déontologie de la
sécurité la défense des droits des
enfants c'est-à-dire à une pelure i did
un contenu très plurielle et diversifiée
le défenseur des droits disposera sous
sa seule autorité de pouvoir dans caisse
de pouvoir quasi juridictionnelle et
d'un pouvoir d'influencé d'actions
auprès de l'opinion publique et des
juridictions nous ne contestons ni le
contenu ni la logique de ses pouvoirs en
eux mêmes mais voyons bien qu'ils sont
évidemment contredit par le fait qu' il
est nommé par le seul exécutif le
président de la république et donc pour
nous ce n'est pas une garantie en soi
une garantie en soit je le précise de
son indépendance ce qui garantit
l'indépendance c'est justement le
pluralisme la collégialité la
pluridisciplinarité donc que nous
contestons effectivement 7e renforcement
des pouvoirs du défenseur des droits 7
croissance continue dans le débat je
parle même pas dans la réalité puisque
de la réalité nous n'avons point pour
l'instant mais déjà dans le débat de
cette omnipotence du défenseur des
droits
si la raison pour laquelle nous de
continuer de défendre nous continuerons
de défendre l'idée que six défenseurs
des droits il y as puisque la
constitution en a décidé ainsi il faut
que aux comptes
ceux qui sont censés travailler sous sa
tutelle et une part d'indépendance et
une part de collégialité de
pluridisciplinarité qui leur permettent
effectivement deux d'acquérir de
l'expertisé et de l'indépendance donc
les amendements 73 que je n'ai pas pu
des formes à cause de mon absence et le
74 mais c'est la même chose c'est de
mentionner à égalité d'intervention avec
le défenseur les adjoints ceci en
conformité totale avec le renforcement
des capacités d'expertisé et de pouvoir
que nous entendons leur conférer merci
monsieur en porter sur ces deux
amendements concernant 90 qui était
défendue tout à l'heure et il n'est pas
possible ou pas
si c'est le 73 mon nom fléché oui
exactement
j'ai passé de 46 sur les papes
alors cet amendement 46 tenta rétabli
des dispositions qui ont été supprimés
par la commission des lois
si le défenseur doit indiquer pour
chaque saisine rejeter les démarches
entreprendre pour se résoudre les
problèmes soulevés il deviendra un
véritable l'évier temps un gigantesque
centre de renseignements administratifs
et il pourra plus du tout assumer sa
mission
c'est par conséquent en dehors de sa
vocation de constitutionnel et j'aimais
donc un avis défavorable à cet
amendement
il en est de même pour l'amendement qui
suit qui est le même
l'amendement de lure 73 sepa 74 et il ne
s'agit pas de collégialité dans ce
domaine il s'agit de le refuser de
donner des charges supplémentaires non
prévue par les textes et qui d'ailleurs
n'existe nulle part ailleurs tu vois pas
pourquoi on devrait transformer et le
défenseur des droits en avocat de chacun
chacune des parties qui font un recours
devant lui monsieur ministre l'avis
défavorable serait deux abonnements
merci je mets au voir l'amendement 46
pas d'explications de vote qui pour qui
contre l'amendement n'est pas adoptée
même voix sur le 73 pas d'opposition je
vous en remercie je me vois l'article 20
dans son ensemble qui est pour l'article
20 qui contre partie que vince est
adoptée article 21
deux amendements discussion commune
amendements identiques un amendement 75
qui est présenté par josiane
mathon-poinat oui merci monsieur le
président mais nous poursuivons la même
la même logique et nous tentons quand
même
essayer d'élargir un petit peu les
pouvoirs et nous proposons donc
d'élargir aux adjoints et et au
défenseur des enfants les pouvoirs qui
sont prévus pour le défenseur des droits
il apparaît tout à fait légitime de les
associer aux suites à donner à une
réclamation dans la mesure où elles sont
de leur champ de compétence à moins
vraiment et c'est ce qui apparaît là de
leur donner aucun pouvoir
merci un membre de mon 91
richard yong merci monsieur président
même même amendement même même objet
d'élargir donc les prérogatives du
défenseur des enfants pour qu'ils
puissent émettre des recommandations
visant le respect des droits des enfants
je rappelle qu'il s'agit là d'une
proposition d'amendement de l'unicef ce
qui lui donne un caractère je crois
assez solennel monsieur le rapporteur
bon tout d'abord ces amendements qui
tente un permettent aux adjoints du
défenseur des droits de ces
recommandations
en application de l'article 21 ces
amendements sont en fait déjà satisfait
pas les dispositions de l'article 11 ha
qui permettent au défenseur des droits
de délégués à ses adjoints
certaines de ses attributions dont
l'élaboration de recommandations
je rappelle également monsieur young
qu'aucun organisme extérieur au sénat ou
à l'assemblée nationale n'a le pouvoir
d'amendement
nous sommes là vont ainsi que le
gouvernement
monsieur le ministre
écoutez je partage l'avis du rapporteur
selon lequel ces abonnements sont
satisfaits par un exposé a donc je
demande leur retrait sinon à vis des
favoris bien ils sont maintenus ils sont
maintenus je vais donc ensemble ces deux
amendements on voit quels sont ceux qui
sont pour contre six amendements ne sont
pas adopté un amendement 92
il est présenté par richard yung même
même nature donc je ne développe pas je
note quand même que vous ne semblez pas
aimé l'unicef et je le regrette parce
que c'est une belle organisation qui a
une belle vocation qui est monsieur le
rapporteur satisfait par l'article 11
qui permet aux défenseurs des droits des
gays ses adjoints l'exercice des
attributions qui détient en vertu de
l'article 21 vont par conséquent demande
de retrait ou défavorable merci je mets
ou voir l'amendement 92 qui est pour et
qui est contre un rendement 92 et pas
adopté un amendement 47
il est présenté pour le groupe
socialiste
badaoui
jugez plutôt
oui monsieur le président oui oui
l'article 21 du projet de loi permet aux
défenseurs des droits d'émettre tout
recommandations de nature à régler les
difficultés dont il est saisi en
première lecture le sénat avait précisé
que le défenseur des droits pourrait
formuler des recommandations tendant à
remédier à tout fait ou toute pratique
qu'il estime discriminatoire ou en
prévenir le renouvellement
cette disposition pouvait ne pas
paraître indispensable dans la mesure où
le défenseur des droits peut
s'autosaisir et où le premier alinéa de
l'article 26 ans lui donne un pouvoir
général de recommandation mais dès lors
que l'assemblée nationale a complété
cette disposition prévoyant que le
défenseur des droits pourrait également
formulé des recommandations tendant à
remédier à tout fait ou a tout à rouiba
toutes pratiques contraires à l'intérêt
supérieur de l'enfant
il convient par souci de cohérence
d'étendre à présent le pouvoir de
recommandation du défenseur des droits
au respect des règles de déontologie par
les personnels exerçant des activités de
sécurité sur le territoire de la
république
tel est l'objet sur le président du
présent amendement terrain sur lequel
elle sert à porter le président à
première lecture le sénat avait ajouté à
l'article 21 une précision reprenant la
loi de décembre 2004 relative à la halde
afin de bien marquer que le statut du
défenseur des droits ne comportait
aucune diminution de pouvoir cependant
comme le rappelle l'objet de
l'amendement le premier alinéa de
l'article 21 donne maintenant au
défenseur des droits un pouvoir général
de recommandation aussi n'est-il pas
nécessaire de le compléter par un
troisième alinéa donc sagesse
monsieur le ministre est même avis bien
à mort nous avons sur l'amendement 47
que vient de présenter roland courteau 2
heavy de sagesse je vais donc consulté
le sénat
quels sont ceux qui sont pour quels sont
ceux qui sont contre l'amendement est
adopté a maintenant 48 la parade et à
richard yung
merci monsieur le président il s'agit
par cet amendement de rendre un peu plus
ferme
au fond les recommandations que le
défenseur des droits
rendre publiques ces ces observations
nous proposons donc de substituer à
l'expression peut rendre public
l'expression rend public
nous pensons qu'il est important qu'il
lorsqu'il établit un rapport spécial
audard au stade ultime de la procédure
d'injonction de prévoir cette publicité
systématique
merci monsieur le rapporteur eh bien
monsieur le président je vais faire
plaisir à monsieur young en effet la
commission a donné un avis favorable à
cet amendement qui tend à prévoir que si
le défenseur des droits décident
d'établir un rapport spécial après
qu'une personne n'a pas donné suite à
une injonction et qui rend public ce
rapport cela peut en effet rendre le
dispositif plus dissuasif par conséquent
je tiens à vous faire plaisir
avis favorable monsieur le ministre est
un plaisir partagé
lui nice voilà donc moi je voudrais dire
à monsieur young et à monsieur le
rapporteur que je ne partage pas leur
avis sur ce point et c'est chacun a le
droit de s'exprimer et je voudrais dire
simplement pourquoi je pense que obligé
le défenseur des droits à rendre
publique la jonction qu'il a donnée ou
le rapport qu'il a établies à la suite
d'une injonction
c'est aussi se placer dans une situation
de rigidité par ailleurs il faudra
véritablement voir si la personne
concernée par la jonction a bien été
mises en état de répondre parce que
c'est notre principe du contradictoire
seraient mises à mal par cette
disposition et être sûr que on aura bien
l'ensemble de la question et on veut
dire qu'on va considérablement
rigidifier les opérations et c'est la
raison pour laquelle je donne un avis
défavorable a expliqué sur le jeu n'en
vaut pas alors je vais consulter le
sénat sur l'amendement 48 cas présentés
richard yong en vous rappelant que la
commission a donné un avis favorable est
que le gouvernement donne un avis
défavorable à l'or qui est pour cet
amendement qui est contre l'amendement
est adopté
nous en arrivons à l'amendement 93
monsieur young
merci monsieur le président c'est un
amendement qui est dans la lignée d'un
certain nombre d'amendements que nous
avons déposées précédemment qui vise à
compléter donc l'article 21 ans
précisant que lorsqu'il s'agit des
droits des enfants et de ce qu'on
appelle l'intérêt supérieur pas pourquoi
subir hier m'envoie un intérêt supérieur
le défenseur des droits demande l'avis
du défenseur des enfants
avant de mettre en oeuvre les
prérogatives qui sont dans l'article 21
c'est une façon de reconnaître la
spécificité de la défense des droits des
enfants
si sur la porter monsieur ne peux pas
vous donner satisfaction à chaque fois à
la c'est un avis défavorable parce que
cet amendement aboutirait à prévoir une
double consultation matière de droits de
l'enfant consultation du collège dont
l'adjoint fait partie d'ailleurs
et donc il serait à la fois et
dédoublement de la personnalité
en tant que membre du collège sont tous
il avait présidé ce moment là il est il
aurait donné un avis au type du collège
et puis un autre avis à titre individuel
puis consultation du défenseur des
enfants je ne les vendra des droits pour
la mise en oeuvre voire de
recommandations d'injonctions procédures
beaucoup trop lourde en outre je
rappelle donc que les adjoints sont
membres du collège et par conséquent ils
ont eu tout loisir de s'exprimer dans le
cadre de celui-ci
donc avis défavorable merci monsieur le
ministre je voudrais dire que cet
amendement est dans le droit fil de la
bande mans précédent soit une caisse
j'ai donné un avis défavorable et je
veux à nouveau donné un avis défavorable
parce que monsieur young vos deux
amendements
pendant le même sens s'ils sont adoptés
tous les deux il y aura plus de rapport
spécial est simplement on vise par ces
deux amendements a supprimé le rapport
spécial et ce rapport spécial était un
vrai progrès parce qu'il permettait aux
défenseurs des droit d'intervenir d'une
façon particulière et deux passes
rapport spécial de bien marquer que
l'injonction été suivi et qu'il y avait
là un plus dans la garantie des droits
par le rapport à l'amendement précédent
vous avez qui a eu un succès donc j'ai
plus rien de dire on rend public
obligatoirement le rapport spécial c'est
à dire qu'il y aura plus est ici avec
cet amendement
vous visez à peu près au même objet
c'est à dire à faire en sorte que
défenseur des droits n'utilise pas le
rapport spécial
c'est la raison pour laquelle je vis des
femmes merci je me vois l'amendement 93
qui a reçu deux avis défavorables qui
pour quiconque
mon en 93 des phases adopté je mets aux
voix l'article 21 dans son ensemble qui
pour quiconque trafic 21 adopté
l'article 21 bis à est supprimé article
28 cents amendements 94 opéra d'état
richard yung
merci monsieur le président c'est un
amendement qui vient compléter le
l'article 21 bis alinéa 1 qui dit le
défenseur des droits peut procéder à la
résolution amiable des différends portés
à sa connaissance et par voie de
médiation
donc on voit bien l'esprit qu'il y à là
mais dire que nous pouvons mais nous
pensons que ceci ne s'appliquent pas au
cas où les droits des enfants sont
concernés par ce qu'il y a évidemment un
déséquilibre la médiation la recherche
d'un accord d'un compromis peut
s'imaginer facilement et même
souhaitable dans le cas où deux adultes
ayant leurs raisons sont en cause mais
quand il ya un adulte et un enfant havre
a priori de la forcerie deux enfants
nous pensons que cette mécanique là ne
s'applique pas c'est pour ça que nous
voulons la mettre un peu à l'écart de
cet article 21 10 sur l'impôt club cet
amendement tend à écarter l'utilisation
du pouvoir de médiation dans les
situations mettant en cause les droits
de l'enfant une telle restriction ne
paraît pas justifié
en effet même lorsque l'intérêt de
l'enfant est en jeu une médiation doit
pouvoir être conduite par exemple entre
les parents les services sociaux
et c'est la raison pour laquelle j'aime
un avis défavorable ce ministre je
mettrai le même avis d'ailleurs lors de
son audition par le rapporteur
la défenseure des enfants a indiqué que
la médiation constitue est ce votre
principal d'intervention et permettait
de résoudre un grand nombre de
difficultés par l'intervention des
correspondants territoriaux
donc avis défavorable
je me vois l'amendement 94 qui pour
quiconque la moment mais pas adopté je
me vois lartigue 21 bis dans son
ensemble quels sont ceux qui sont pour
contre 1 l'africain vis et adopté un
article 21
tu es sur lequel j'ai un amendement 49
richard yung merci monsieur le président
à l'article 21 terre nous voudrions par
cet amendement ré ré introduire en
quelque sorte ou introduire rajouter ce
qui concerne les règles de déontologie
c'est à dire en font ce qu'étaient les
activités de feu la cnds l'article 21
prévoit terre prévoit que le défenseur
des droits considère les réclamations
des personnes victimes de discrimination
mais ne parle pas des cas de personnes
qui sont victimes du non respect des
règles de déontologie
donc nous voulons rajouter ce cas de
figure sur à porter dans l'arctique 21
heures été introduit par le sénat en
première lecture
pour reprendre une disposition de la loi
relative à la halde
en effet en matière de discrimination
les victimes sont confrontés souvent à
de grandes difficultés pour établir la
preuve de leur discrimination
c'est pourquoi il peut être important
que les défenseurs les assiste dans la
constitution de leurs dossiers
l'aide du défenseur des droits peut être
également utile aux enfants en revanche
cette logique d'assistance dans d'autres
démarches par est moins évidente et
c'est la raison pour laquelle en toute
hypothèse on peut penser que le
défenseur des droits aidera les
personnes qui en auraient besoin à
identifier les procédures adaptées à
leur cas donc j'ai pas de style it et à
cet amendement sagesse ces ministres
avaient défavorable alors sagesse de la
commission un avis défavorable avis
défavorable du gouvernement
pas d'explications de vote quels sont
ceux qui sont pour contre le moment les
pas adopter un moment 140 madame
garriaud-maylam merci monsieur le
président cet amendement vise à
compléter l'article 21 terre relatif à
l'assistance éventuelle du défenseur des
droits dans la constitution d'un dossier
alors bien évidemment j'imagine monsieur
le rapporteur monsieur le ministre que
vous allez me dire que rien dans la loi
organique
n'empêche que le défenseur des droits
puisse donner des conseils quant aux
démarches à entreprendre dans la
constitution des dossiers déposés
lorsqu'une affaire inclut une dimension
internationale pourtant il me semble
essentiel de préciser que cette aide est
possible y compris lorsque ces affaires
inclus cette dimension internationale
j'aurais eu envie de dire surtout lorsqu
il y a une dimension internationale mais
bien évidemment je ne pouvais aller
jusque là car de telles affaires
lorsqu'elle concerne nos concitoyens à
l'étranger nécessite une expertise
particulière qu'il sera important que le
service en charge des ressources
humaines du défenseur des droits
prennent en compte sur le plan de
l'information des usagers monsieur le
rapporteur cette précision est également
essentiel car trop de nos concitoyens se
sentent désemparés
lorsque leur affaire concerne un litige
impliquant un organisme français un
organisme à l'étranger ou un
ressortissant à l'étranger et je pense
notamment aux déplacements illicites
d'enfants ce sont des affaires complexes
j'ai déjà eu l'occasion de le dire hier
et je trouve vraiment une telle mention
serait très utile pour l'information de
nos compatriotes à l'étranger pour
qu'ils sachent qu effectivement il
pourrait bénéficier d'une assistance du
défenseur des droits je vous remercie
sur un porteur président cet amendement
à bord d'un naturellement un point très
important est celui des déplacements
illicites d'enfants
j'ai cependant un regret c'est que je
crains que dans sa rédaction il n'y ait
aucune précision utile à porter et je
crains aussi que le défenseur des droits
ne puisse pas faire grand chose dans ce
domaine parce qu'il ya d'autres
organismes qui doivent intervenir
notamment les services de garde des
sceaux d'ailleurs et qui dans ce domaine
sont en première ligne
alors il va de soi que le défenseur des
droits doit intégrer la dimension
internationale il l'a bien on l'a bien
vu à propos du défenseur des enfants
ça fait partie de sa mission lorsqu'il
traitera de telles affaires mais je
pense pas que cet amendement apporte
quoi que ce soit de positif c'est plutôt
un voeu pieux c'est la raison pour
laquelle je demanderai plutôt le retrait
et sinon je serais obligé de mettre un
avis défavorable chemise
merci monsieur le président je voudrais
tout d'abord confirmé ce qu'a dit le
rapporteur
il existe en effet au ministère de la
justice la direction des affaires
civiles et du sceau un bureau qui est
tout entier dédié à la question est en
moi je suis sensible au fait que vous
ayez développer cette question à
plusieurs reprises et je serai moins
sévère que rapporteur je m'en remets à
la sagesse du sénat sur cet amendement
bien l'explication de vote richard yung
si monsieur le président je crois que
cet amendement met le doigt sur un
problème particulièrement sensible vous
avez peut-être vu que la semaine
dernière nous avons eu un long débat sur
le problème des enfants franco japonais
victimes d'enlèvements en cas de
séparation des parents nous sommes donc
je crois assez sensibilisés à cette
question il n'ya pas que le japon qui
est concerné beaucoup d'autres pays
monsieur le garde des sceaux nous savons
qu'il ya une direction ou une sous
direction qui suit ces questions là dans
votre ministère et qui est active et qui
fait des propositions et je crois que
pour notre part l'amendement qui est
proposé là va dans le bon sens et donc
nous le soutiendrons merci christian
cointat ministre mes chers collègues
tout à l'heure notre rapporteur a
reconnu l'intérêt de cette proposition
pour arriver à la conclusion que
finalement elle n'était pas forcément
nécessaire
je crois que ce qu'a dit tout à l'heure
richard yung montre que c'est nécessaire
vous le savez très bien monsieur le
rapporteur
notre pays a une beaucoup de qualités
mais un grand défaut ce grand défaut
c'est de se regarder l'intérieur et non
pas l'extérieur et il est bon que dans
les tests de la texte de loi on rappelle
la dimension internationale voilà
pourquoi ce n'est pas superfétatoire
c'est même au contraire une ouverture un
éclairage et une volonté et donc
j'invite nos collègues à soutenir
l'amendement de joëlle garriaud-maylam
car ce sera une avancée un plus
justement dans la prise en compte de
problèmes extrêmement complexe et
extrêmement douloureux oui je voudrais
remercier mes deux collègues et je
voudrais également faire une précision
dans cet amendement
même si j'ai parlé des déplacements
illicites d'enfants dans l'exposé des
motifs il n'y ait pas fait référence
parce que ce sont des problèmes très
importants à l'international comme je le
dise
il nécessite une expertise spécifique et
comme l'ont très bien dit mes deux
collègues
richard yung et christian cointat il
nous semble important de pouvoir
l'indiqué dans la loi donc puisque
monsieur le ministre appelle à la
sagesse j'espère que mes collègues
suivront cet avis de sagesse et je les
en remercie bien je mets au voie
d'amendement 140 quels sont ceux qui
sont pour et ceux qui sont contre
l'amendement est adopté jeu mais on voit
l'article 21 terre dans son ensemble
quels sont ceux qui sont pour oui il y
en a quelques-uns quand même bien quels
sont ceux qui sont contre adopter un
petit grain de un amendement 95 qui est
présenté par richard llung merci
monsieur le président c'est dans la
logique des observations ou des
amendements que nous avions précédemment
fait donc cet article 22 prévoit en fait
dans son alinéa 1 la possibilité de
conclure des transactions dans les
situations note aurait à connaître le
défenseur nous pensons que là encore
c'est une technique qui est bonne en
général mais pour les raisons que j'ai
évoquées tout à l'heure elle ne
s'applique pas ou peu ou mal au cas où
un enfant et concerner un ou plusieurs
enfants sont concernés
c'est pour ça donc notre amendement vise
à sortir le cas particuliers à
particuliers ou pas des enfants de cet
alinéa et de cet article mais sur la
porter le grand thème de l'article 22 de
nos défenseurs des droits à pouvoirs de
transaction
le défenseur des droits pourrait ainsi
proposer les terres d'une transaction
visant à régler un litige
la transaction constitue selon l'article
2044 du code civil un contrat par
conséquent un mineur n'aurait pas la
capelle
it et de conclure une transaction seul
pourrait le faire ses représentants
légaux
en outre une telle transaction devrait
nécessairement être conforme à l'intérêt
supérieur de l'enfant ce qui a déjà été
dit ce à quoi doivent payer le reste de
défenseur des droits
l'amendement n'apporte donc aucune
précision utile par conséquent avis
défavorable monsieur le ministre mais ma
vie alors je vais tout voir l'amendement
95 qui pour qui et contre l'amendement
95 n'est pas adopté lartigue rennes ii
dans son ensemble qui est pour et qui
est contre partie grandeur est adoptée
lundi 23 n'est pas modifié pratique
vendredi non plus scénario à l'arctique
24 la maman 78 qui est présenté par
eliane assassi merci monsieur le
président donc cet article 24 24 pardon
il est précisé que le défenseur des
droits peut consulter le conseil d'état
et qui peut également rendre public
l'avis émis donc par par le conseil
d'état donc nous nous considérons que
s'agissant d'un avis émanant d'une telle
autorité et donc qui revêt par nature
une certaine importance
il serait plus logique et plus utile
qu'il soit rendu public
il apparaît préférable de l'est ce
défenseur des droits une liberté
d'appréciation la matière en fonction de
l'importance et du contenu de l'avis
rendu donc avis défavorable puis liste
même avis peu d'explications besoin de
jeu mais aux voix qui et pour qui et
pour qui contre l'amendement ne pas
adopter ce mode graphique 24 dans son
ensemble qui pour tes comptes tortigue
rennes 4 2 adopté l'article 24 bis est
supprimé à l'article 25 à 90,96 apparel
et à richard yung
merci monsieur le président donc
c'est sur l' article 25 alinéa 1
l'article 25 alinéa 1 10 le défenseur
des droits peut recommander de procéder
aux modifications législatives ou
réglementaires qui lui paraissent utiles
nous proposons de le compléter et de le
préciser
lalonde même sens en précisant donc il
peut également sur proposition du
défenseur des enfants suggérait toutes
modifications de textes concernant les
droits des enfants et en particulier la
transposition des engagements
internationaux nous pensons qu'un si les
droits des enfants seraient mieux
protégés mais si le second porte sur les
mêmes prérogatives que celle possédé par
l'actuelle défenseure des enfants à
savoir proposer l'intégration de droits
reconnus à l'enfant par des conventions
ratifiées signée par la france
cet amendement est largement satisfaits
par le deuxièmement de l'article 4 du
projet de loi organique qui prévoit que
le défenseur des droits est chargé de
défendre et de promouvoir l'intérêt
supérieur et les droits de l'enfant
consacré par la loi ou par un engagement
international régulièrement ratifiés ou
approuvés par la france conformément à
la mission énoncés à l'article 1er de la
loi du 6 mars 2000 instituant le
défenseur des enfants
par conséquent comme il dit satisfait je
demande le retrait sinon avis
défavorable le ministre l'abonnement 96
est tout à fait satisfait par le premier
alinéa de l'article effet l'agent pour
laquelle je demande à mon tour le
retrait ou avis défavorable maintenu je
le mets aux voix quels sont ceux qui
sont pour contre l'amendement n'est pas
adopté avant le mans 97 sur young
merci monsieur le président je crains
d'avoir la même remarque
alors que c'est un excellent amendement
puisque nous proposons de rajouter que
le défenseur des droits rend un avis sur
tout projet ou proposition de loi
concernant les enfants proposition au
projet de loi venant devant l'une des
assemblées nous pensons que ceci serait
de nature à renforcer la défense du
droit des enfants
merci sur un porteur de l'amendement qui
souhaite que le défenseur des droits
soient systématiquement consulté sur
tout projet ou proposition de loi
concernant les enfants
votre commission est favorable à cet
amendement numéro 97 ainsi qu'à
l'amendement numéro 19 de monsieur
portelli cas le même budget et ce pour
trois raisons la rédaction proposée
particulièrement large et ne vise pas
les droits de l'enfant mais les enfants
général aucune consultation obligatoire
n'est prévu par la loi du 6 mars 2000
instituant un défenseur des enfants
enfin votre commission se rallie à
l'amendement de compromis du
gouvernement qui va venir tout à l'heure
l'amendement numéro 153
et par conséquent j'émets un avis
défavorable à cet amendement
merci le monde 19 été retiré monsieur
lavaud que défavorable sur le 97
défavorable sur les 97 97 deux avis
défavorables
je mets aux voix comme sur ceux qui sont
pour contre l'amendement les pas adopté
un amendement 153 sur lequel on a déjà
l'avis de la commission
oui merci à monsieur le président je
rapporterai la gentillesse de dire que
c'était un bon amendement donc je serai
cours dans sa présentation
il s'agit simplement de religieuses
second alinéa de l'article 27 25 pardon
de la façon suivante il c'est à dire le
défenseur des droits peut être consulté
par le premier ministre sur tout projet
de loi intervenant dans son champ de
compétence et il s'agit donc de donner
est la plénitude de prérogatives au
défenseur des droits
merci on a la vie de dur à porter
auquel il sera bien sûr je mets aux voix
la maman 153 du gouvernement qui et pour
qui contre l'amendement est adopté avant
dans 98 la paralysie tard richard yung
c'est monsieur le président je le
présente jeu si j'ose dire pour mémoire
alors j'imagine la réponse notre
proposition est temps d'élargir ou de
préciser la compétence du défenseur des
enfants et du défenseur des droits donc
dans disons le volet international de la
défense et de la promotion des droits
des enfants nous le spécifions par notre
notre alinéa qui figure ici en en
amendement merci cet amendement est
largement satisfaits par l'alinéa 4 de
l'article 25 inséré par notre commission
cet alinéa prévoit que le défenseur des
droits contribué à la demande du premier
ministre à la préparation et la
définition de la position française dans
les négociations internationales dans
les domaines relevant de son champ de
compétences ce qui inclut naturellement
la défense et la promotion des droits de
l'enfant
en outre il faut signaler que
l'amendement présente une difficulté
majeure
tel qu'il est rédigé le défenseur des
droits devrait en collaboration avec le
défenseur des enfants contribue à la
préparation et à la définition de la
position française dans les négociations
internationales y compris dans le
domaine des relations des citoyens avec
l'administration de la déontologie la
sécurité ou de la lutte contre les
discriminations et de la promotion de
l'égalité ce qui serait pour le moins
curieux
donc avis défavorable ce ministre je
donne également un avis défavorable je
suis élu je partage l'avis du rapporteur
sur le fait que l'abonnement est
largement satisfaits par l'article l
alinéa 4 de cet article et pour ce qui
est de
présence du défenseur des droits à la
représentation française dans les
instances internationales
elle ne peut pas être possible dès lors
que cette position ne peut
constitutionnellement être arrêté que
par le président la république ou le
premier ministre très naturellement cela
est incompatible avec l'indépendance du
défenseur des droits
demande donc le retrait de cet
amendement bien mais c'est humain tenue
je le mets ou voir quels sont ceux qui
sont pour contre l'amendement n'est pas
adopté avant le mans 99
il est défendu monsieur le rapporteur
une incidence sur la politique étrangère
de la france
il apparaît donc nécessaire de demander
l'avis du gouvernement du ministre
je remercie le rapporteur du fait qu'il
ne veut pas donner d'injonction pouvoir
exécutif dans la gestion des affaires
internationales et de la même façon
l'indépendance du défenseur des droits
interdit et qu'ils soient associés à la
définition de la politique étrangère
donc avis défavorable bien pas expliqués
sur le vote je me vois l'amendement 99
qui et pour qui contre l'amendement 99
n'est pas adoptée je veux voilà fi g 5
dans son ensemble pour contre l'afrique
25 états docteur 26 nous amenons
discussion commune 136 et 137 monsieur
young vous pourrez peut-être nous les
présenter ensemble puisqu'ils sont en
discussion commune
merci monsieur le président le 136 est
un amendement de suppression de l'alinéa
1 de l'article 26 qui dit le défenseur
des droits ne peut remettre en cause une
décision juridictionnelle
nous considérons que
cet alinéa va plus loin qu'il n'est
nécessaire et que l'expérience qui a été
acquise en particulier à la halde a
montré à de nombreuses reprises que les
observations qu'elle présentait devant
les juridictions
après avoir été parfois rejetée en
première instance ont été accueillis
favorablement en appel ou au second
degré et ont regardé principe
constitutionnel de séparation des
pouvoirs et d'indépendance de l'autorité
judiciaire la suppression de cet alinéa
ne peut être interprétée comme
autorisant le défenseur devra remettre
en cause la décision juridictionnelle
même quand elle n'est pas définitive
voilà pour le premier le premier
amendement le 136 et pour l'amendement
nous souhaitons compléter l'alinéa 1 de
l'article 26 par les mots devenus
définitifs donc une décision devenue
définitive
donc chers collègues nationaux rapporte
l'avis de la commission ces deux
amendements 136 il va de soi que le fait
de prévoir que le défenseur des droits
ne peut remettre en cause une décision
juridictionnelle n'aura pas pour effet
d'interdire à celui-ci de présenter des
observations en appel ou en cassation
en outre le fait de supprimer cette
disposition pourrait être interprété
comme autorisant le défenseur des droits
à remettre en cause une décision
juridictionnelle
par conséquent je demanderai leur
retrait sinon avis défavorable et pour
l'amendement 237
l'amendement prévoit que le défenseur
des droits ne pourrait remettre en cause
une décision juridictionnelle devenue
définitive
cela va de soi les auteurs de
l'amendement craignent que le défenseur
des droits se voit contester le droit de
présenter des observations en appel ou
en cassation
cette crainte paraît totalement
infondées et la prose mais la précision
apportée n'apparaît pas nécessaire donc
demande de retrait ou avis défavorable
sioniste
merci de répression je veux dire deux
mots sur ces deux amendements
parce qu'il me semble remettre en cause
un principe particulièrement important
et je crois que cela mérite une réponse
au fond l'amendement un numéro 136 qui
vise à supprimer le premier alinéa de
l'article 26 a pour conséquence de
mettre en bas de battre en brèche un
principe fondamental auquel je suis
personnellement très attachée qui est ce
lui et que ne peut remettre en cause une
décision juridictionnelle que par
l'exercice des voies de recours prévues
si on sort de cette règle et si on
permet à qui que ce soit critiquer une
décision de justice autrement que par
les voies de recours
il faudra pas se plaindre du résultat
obtenu et je crois qu'il faut rester là
c'est la raison pour laquelle je suis
tout à fait hostile à l amendement de
suppression
quand un amendement de repli et qui
disent que les décision devenue
définitive il n'y a pas lieu de
permettre aux défenseurs de droit de
remettre lui-même en cause une décision
de justice fut-elle provisoire il
appartient au parti de le faire en
utilisant les voies de recours et que
très naturellement dans ce cade ronald
défenseur des droits pourra faire valoir
son point de vue dans le cadre d'une
assistance en appel ou en cassation
pour ces deux motifs je suis tout à fait
défavorable à ces amendements
merci monsieur le ministre je vais trop
loin
l'amendement 136 qui a reçu un avis
défavorable de la commission
environnement qui est pour et qui est
contre un moment 136 n'est pas adopté
l'amendement 137 même vote
je vous en remercie mes deux amendements
ne vont pas adopté un amendement sans
qu'ils aient présenté par richard yung
merci monsieur présence d'un amendement
de précisions
souhaitons préciser qu'il s'agit dans
cet article 26 d'inviter le défenseur
des droits pour le défenseur des enfants
c'est donc une simple précision c'est le
rapporteur a parlé de nombreuses fois le
défenseur des enfants n'a aucune
existence constitutionnel en revanche le
défenseur des droits pourra ensuite
délégué cette représentation
d'observation à chacun de ses adjoints
et en particulier au défenseur des
enfants
le cas échéant conformément à l'article
11 à tel qu'il résulte des travaux votre
commission de ce point de vue
l'amendement est donc largement
satisfaits et c'est la raison pour
laquelle je demande le retrait
sinon avis défavorable merci monsieur
ministres maintenus maintenu monsieur
young il est maintenu très bien je le
mets ou voit quels sont ceux qui sont
pour et ceux qui sont contre
ma maman n'est pas adopté un amendement
141 madame garriaud-maylam oui merci
monsieur le président cet amendement
vise à compléter l'alinéa 2 de l'article
26 en indiquant qu'une lorsqu'une
juridiction est appelée à statuer sur un
déplacements illicites d'enfants ou sur
l'autorité parentale alors que l'un des
parents est étranger l'information sous
forme d'observation écrites ou orales du
défenseur du droit ou sur sa délégation
du défenseur des enfants est
systématique
une fois de plus nous nous penchons sur
ces questions épineuses de déplacements
illicites d'enfants permettre au
défenseur des droits ou aux délégués aux
droits des enfants de sensibiliser par
exemple les juridictions étrangères à la
jurisprudence sur ces quatre
déplacements d'infos pratiques
étrangères aux différentes possibilités
de règlement du litige dans l'intérêt
supérieur de l'enfant constituerait une
avancée significative dans la gestion de
ses affaires complexes
il s'agit bien sûr d'un amendement
d'appel je suis conscient de la volonté
du gouvernement par cette loi organique
de doter le défenseur des droits d'un
cadre institutionnel souple qu'il pourra
ensuite lui-même adapté aux exigences de
sa fonction
toutefois il me semble essentiel dans
ces cas de protection de l'enfance qu'un
certain nombre de garanties soit
inscrite dans la loi
vous le savez je vais cosigné les
amendements du portelli visant à
maintenir un défenseur des enfants
indépendant puisque ceux ci semblent
s'avérait impossible il me semble
essentiel de garantir à l'adjoint en
charge de la protection de l'enfance une
réelle autonomie sur un certain nombre
de sujets et en particulier sur ces
problèmes de déplacements illicites
d'enfants
si l'obligation d'une intervention
systématique du défenseur des enfants
dans ce type de procédure aux
conséquences extrêmement lourdes
puisqu'elles peuvent aller jusqu'à la
légalisation de l'enlèvement d'un enfant
vers un pays étranger avec à la clé
l'impossibilité de revoir l'un des
parents d'en apprendre la langue n'est
pas inscrite dans la loi il ya fort à
parier qu'elle demeurera exceptionnel
pourtant ce défenseur des droits des
enfants pourrait constituer la personne
clé dans des procès où trop souvent nos
juridictions se dessaisisse ou prennent
des décisions mettant en péril la
capacité de l'enfant maintenir un
contact avec ses deux parents faute de
sensibilisation des avocats et des juges
aux enjeux de ses déplacements illicites
d'enfants représentant du défenseur des
droits qui connaîtrait le cadre légal et
la jurisprudence pays par pays de
préférence serait un formidable pas en
avant en liaison bien évidemment avec
les bureaux du ministère de la justice
en charge de ces dossiers pour résoudre
ces problèmes mais si mesure importe
prévoit l'intervention systématique du
défenseur des droits dans un cas de
figure très précis à savoir lorsqu'une
juridiction est appelée à statuer sur un
déplacements illicites d'enfants ou sur
l'autorité parentale
alors que l'un des parents est étranger
sans sous-estimer la gravité de la
situation visée il convient de laisser
aux juridictions aux parties en cause et
au défenseur des droits lui même
d'apprécier au cas par cas
in concreto si l'intervention de ce
dernier est utile rappelons que si le
défenseur des droits
demande lui même à intervenir dans une
procédure son intervention est de droit
par conséquent je ne vois pas l'intérêt
de rendre obligatoire et systématique
cette intervention
c'est la raison pour laquelle je
préférerais un retrait sinon avis
défavorable sur le ministre merci
monsieur le président j'ai bien compris
quand même gagné aux médias avaient
annoncé cet amendement comme étant un
amendement d'appel et je partage l avis
du rapporteur sur le fond je pense que
les juridictions sont plutôt bien
informés de ces questions nous avons
actuelle peut pas vous laisser dire ça
le sénateur de la loire actuellement
certain nombre d'affaires assez délicate
et qui sont pendantes devant des
juridictions et je suis prêt d'ailleurs
à rappeler via les procureurs généraux 1
le contenu de la convention de la haye
il y a aucun problème et je pense pas qu
est la bonne solution soit la présence
obligatoire du défenseur des droits
je pense que ça alourdirait les
procédures et que ça irait plutôt à
l'encontre du but que vous poursuivez je
vous le dis je suis prêt augmentée la
formation il le ferait pas
l'intermédiaire des procureurs généraux
et aux bénéfices de cette assurance je
me propose de retirer votre abonnement
bien malin garriaud-maylam oui merci
beaucoup monsieur le ministre c'est
avancer parce que les choses ne sont pas
aussi simples qu'elles le paraissent la
convention de la haye ne résout pas tous
les problèmes
loin de là nous avons besoin de
meilleures informations de meilleure
formation des magistrats en ce domaine
est donc vraiment je vous remercie
beaucoup de ces avancées et au bénéfice
de ce que vous venez de nous dire bien
évidemment je retire mon amendement
l'amendement et retirait je mets au voir
l'article 26 ans son ensemble qui est
pour contre un prix grammy 6 et adoptée
à 26 villes un amendement 101 richard
yung merci monsieur le président dans la
lignée des amendements précédent il
s'agit de rajouter de préciser que le
défenseur des enfants peut participer à
ces actions de communication et
d'information merci monsieur rapporteur
longuement parlé des pouvoirs des
adjoints
dans ce domaine il en est comme dans les
autres le défenseur des droits déléguera
s'il le juge nécessaire
mais il n'est donc pas possible de
prévoir que le défenseur des enfants
assure la promotion des droits de
l'enfant
seul le défenseur des droits peut le
faire donc avis défavorable fumiste même
avis je me voilà moment sain qui pour
qui compte on ne s'en est pas de créer
un moment sont trois dans la même lignée
j'imagine avec la même le même type de
réponse
nous voulons viser la convention
international relatif aux droits des
enfants comme un des points important de
l'action que pourrait avoir le défenseur
des droits aux son substitut le
défenseur des enfants sur un porteur
président par conséquent avis
défavorable c'est au défenseur des
droits d'assurer cette mission et pas à
déléguer à l'adjoint qu'il a nommé
monsieur michaud et ma vie je mets au
voie d'amendement 103 qui et pour qui et
contre sa maman centre n'est pas adoptée
je veux voir article 26 visant son
ensemble qui est pour et qui est contre
artix 26 bis et adopte en afrique 26 ter
avec 1,2 avant deux amendements
trois amendements discussion commune
deux amendements identiques des
amendements 50 et 79 l'amendement 50 rue
chez young
merci monsieur le président il s'agit de
préciser
le 26 père qui dit le défenseur des
droits saisi les autorités locales
compétentes de tout élément etc nous
prêts nous voudrions précisé dans le
cadre de sa mission de défense des
droits et des intérêts de lait des
enfants le défenseur des droits saisit
le président du conseil général de toute
situation d'enfants nous voulons précisé
l'autorité à laquelle s'adressera le
défenseur des enfants vous le savez
aussi bien que moi en mieux que moi le
sait le président du conseil général ou
le conseil général qui sont les premiers
responsables de ces actions
merci sur un porteur de 20 $ dans un
mouvement identique pour le groupe crc
il est présenté par deuxième au total
oui merci monsieur le président en
première lecture le projet de loi a été
amendée pour prendre en compte une de
dispositions inscrites dans la loi de
2000 créant le défenseur des enfants et
donnant compétence ou président du
conseil général pour les affaires
susceptibles de justifier l'intervention
des services de l'aide sociale à
l'enfance
elle l'a fait en émettant des réserves
l'une a été fessé par l'assemblée
nationale qui a rendu la saisine
obligatoire l'autre portant sur la
mention du président du conseil général
à laquelle elle est préférée celle
d'autorités locales au motif que la
compétence du président du conseil
général ne faisait pas l'objet d'une
disposition organique et que toute
modification ultérieure de ces
compétences exigerait donc une révision
de la loi organique dont nous examinons
le projet donc je note que lorsqu'il
s'agit de nombreuses lois et autres
notamment en matière de sécurité et de
justice pénale perspective de réviser
les lois empilées les unes sur les
autres noms nous pose aucun problème
or là il ne serait pas logique de
contourner la loi du 5 mars 2007
réformant la protection de l'enfance
donc nous considérons avec l'association
des départements de france d'ailleurs
non pas qu'ils nous dictent
mais qui nous donne un avis et nous
suivons parce que nous le partageons que
le rôle du président du conseil général
est bien le chef de file de la
protection de l'enfance et qui donc il
faut adapter ce texte à la
reconnaissance de son rôle
merci alors on a encore un amendement
104 qui est en discussion commune
il est présenté par richard yung ainsi
monsieur le président il est dans la
même philosophie que les amendements les
deux amendements que nous venons de voir
c'est un amendement quelque sorte de
repli merci monsieur le rapporteur sur
les trois amendements
si vous voulez bien monsieur le
président je ne débuterai avec les deux
premiers amendements
d'ailleurs madame mathon poinat déjà
répondu en fin de compte
véritable fond de la question c'est à
dire qu'il ya une impossibilité
technique à suivre les auteurs des deux
amendements
on ne peut pas dans une loi organique
modifié en réalité des dispositions qui
relèvent de la loi ordinaire
par conséquent à partir du moment où on
citait dans la loi organique le
président du département où le loup le
département lui même à chaque fois qu'on
allait toucher aux compétences
départementales on allait être obligé de
modifier la loi organique
donc c'est pas possible c'est la raison
que pour laquelle pour des six strictes
raisons techniques
on ne peut pas se rallier à ces deux
amendements et ce sera donc un avis
défavorable
alors en ce qui concerne le troisième
amendement qui est un peu différent de
nature c'est un amendement qui se
présente comme un amendement technique
de coordination avec la loi du 5 mars
2007 réformant la protection de
l'enfance
je n'ai pas personnellement là une idée
très précise sur cette question c'est
pour ça que je demanderai la vie du
gouvernement et la commission si
ralliera
monsieur le ministre merci de jeux
payants sur les deux premiers et un
moment je crois qu'il faut simplement
rappeler que lorsque dans la loi on
parle du préfet on dit jamais le préfet
ont dit les représentants de l'état dans
le département
et là c'est la même chose on parle des
autorités locales compétentes
c'est le parallélisme des formes parce
que oui
jamais il ya préfet il y as représentant
de l'état dans le département il
il a d'ailleurs changé de nom parfois et
vous savez bien commissaire de la
république monsieur le doyen commissaire
du allemand s'est lui commissaire de la
république sèche pas le fils de monsieur
bonhomme donc tout va bien
ainsi et je crois qu'il faut à rester là
donc avis défavorable sur ces deux
amendements
quand un amendement numéro 1 104 il
n'apporte pas de véritable amélioration
par rapport à la rédaction actuelle qui
reprend celle retenue dans la loi du 6
mars 2000 instituant le défenseur des
enfants auxquels vous avez dit tout
votre attachement
donc on essaye de reprendre chaque fois
que cela est possible dans la loi tout
ce qui concerne le défenseur des enfants
avis défavorable miel alors je mets
ouvrant les deux amendements identiques
pas d'explications de vote de man 50 et
79 qui pour vincent voulait parler je
lui donne la parole excusez-moi
l'instant de distraction je voudrais
dire que sur les deux premiers amours
soit deux premiers amendements
je voterai content parce qu'il peut
actuellement on est en train de modifier
la loi sur les collectivités
territoriales
on peut très bien avoir un département
ou la région fusionne deux départements
où les deux départements fusionne avec
la région et on pourrait se retrouver
avec plus de président de conseil rural
ce serait le président d'une seule
assemblée et c est donc ça poserait un
problème inextricable
alors je le dis d'autant plus que ça
n'apporte strictement rien de mettre le
terme président de conseil général
donc moi je crois que
ces deux les deux premiers amendements
sont pas pertinents par contre je
soutiendrai le troisième comment je
trouve dont je trouve qu'il a certaines
intérêts merci de ces compléments qui
vont permettre cela va s'exprimer en
toute clarté donc sur les deux premiers
amendements qui est pour et qui est
contre et deux amendements sont pas
adoptées sur l'amendement 104 qui est
pour et qui est contre
dans son cas ce n'est pas adopté je mets
au voir l'article dans son ensemble 26
ter qui pour contre l'article 26 ter et
adopté après l'article 26 ter deux
amendements un moment 76 qui est
présenté par la présidente nicole borvo
cohen-seat merci monsieur le président
alors envoyé sa relève bien de la loi
organique puisqu'on va pas dans le
détail de la société civile
alors cet amendement est totalement
inspiré du président de la halde
l'actuel je dis tout de suite la halde
n'est pas un groupe de pression
économique
un lobby économique comme on en connaît
d'autres quelquefois qui font des
amendements puisque la halde fait cette
probable président actuel de la halde
qui n'est pas hostile si je le gens
croient sa nomination est ce qu'il dit à
la création de défenseur des droits
mais néanmoins qui sur la base de
l'expertisé justement de la halde
voyez que l'expertisé des autorités elle
elle a un intérêt parce qu'elle permet
de voir comment on peut avoir agir sur
de certaines comportement disposition
des alors l'occurrence discrimination il
ne peut proposer de consulter la société
civile
donc moi je dirais la recherche
l'université le monde économique les
associations ajoutant les organisations
syndicales qui sont souvent oubliés
alors qu elles sont représentatives du
monde du travail
donc bien sûr il ya les collèges mais on
voit bien que les collèges
d'abord leur composition leur nombre et
leur consultation devient très aléatoire
dans votre dispositif
donc ça nous paraît pas être suffisant
et ce défenseur des droits homme
omnipotent et puissant tout seul qui
prend ses décisions auraient
effectivement bien serait bien inspiré
sur la base de l'expérience notamment de
la halde mais d'autres aussi il faut
bien le dire de d'avoir des échanges
réels et de les organiser donc la loi
ordinaire on peut le faire ou des
décrets avec des représentants de la
société civile
merci 1re amendements identiques
l'amendement 138 est défendu il est
défendu je vous remercie monsieur le
rapporteur rien n'interdira défenseur
des droits sans base légale particulière
de consulter régulièrement les membres
de la société civile par quelques moyens
que ce soit s'il tentait que la notion
de société civile soient claires je sais
pas très bien ce à quoi ça correspond et
c'est la raison pour laquelle je
demanderai pour les deux amendements qui
n'apporte pas grand chose de plus par
rapport aux pouvoirs du défenseur des
droits
le retrait sinon avis défavorable ce
ministre fait pas sens je remercie et je
veux simplement dire aux auteurs de ces
deux amendements que très naturellement
je suis est défavorable parce qu'il me
semble d'abord contraire à l'article 2
de la loi
je rappelle que le défenseur des droits
est une autorité indépendante et qui
l'organisent comme ils l'entendent et
les consultations qu'il peut mener donc
tout texte tirait dans le sens contraire
ne peut avoir qu un avis défavorable ce
qui est le cas bien
pas d'explications de vote je je mets
aux voix ces deux amendements quels sont
ceux qui sont pour
on prend finalement ne sont pas adoptées
dans un marigot à l'article 27 à 28 27
l'amendement dit ça a été retiré j'ai
donc deux amendements présentés par le
groupe socialiste a normalement 51
monsieur young puis après l'amendement
sont cinq
merci monsieur le président l'amendement
51 vise à compléter le rapport
obligatoire en quelque sorte qui est
remis au président de la république par
le défenseur des droits et couvrant son
activité générale nous proposons de le
compléter par un rapport traitant des
différentes activités thématiques qui
seront les siennes puisqu'il a repris
les différentes activités que vous
connaissez merci alors monsieur le
rapporteur a nommé en discussion le 105
monsieur young puisqu'ils sont en
discussion commune sur le 105 nous
rajoutons simplement la référence au
défenseur des enfants
merci vous aidera porter sur le
président cet amendement le premier de
51 paraît un peu curieux
il prévoit que le défenseur des droits
présente chaque année un rapport général
qui comprend un rapport relatif à chacun
de ses domaines de compétence seller les
poupées gigognes ou des matriochkas
comment un rapport peut-il comprendre
d'autres rapports nous avons préféré une
autre rédaction
la notion d' annexes thématiques
retenues par la commission est beaucoup
plus claire c'est la raison pour
laquelle je demanderai leur retrait de
cet amendement
sinon avis défavorable et quant à
l'amendement 105 il apparaît peu clair
il s'agit s'il s'agit de prévoir un
rapport spécifique consacrée aux droits
de l'enfant
il est satisfait par la rédaction
adoptée par la commission des lois à
l'alinéa cap s'il s'agit de prévoir que
ce rapport spécifique est réalisé avec
le défenseur des enfants
cet amendement apporte une précision qui
ne paraît guère utile
il est bien évident que le défenseur
pourra s'il le souhaite s'appuyer sur
l'expertisé
ses adjoints pour la réalisation des
rapports et annexe thématiques
donc là encore demande de retrait ou
avis défavorable monsieur le ministre
mais ma vie bien fade explications de
vote je me vois l'amendement 51 qui pour
et contre l'amendement les phases adopté
je vous propose de considérer que le
vote est identique sur l'amendement 105
pas d'opposition josé merci je mets aux
voix l'article 27 dans son ensemble qui
est pour quiconque trois parties
craintes étaient adoptées titre quatre
dispositions relatives à l'organisation
et au fonctionnement du défenseur des
droits à l'article 28 un amendement un
rectifier la parole et de christian
cointat et monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
nous le savons tous les difficultés que
rencontrent les français établis hors de
france sont d'une particulière
spécificités elles sont extrêmement
complexes et demandent un minimum
d'expertisé pour être traitées avec
efficacité
c'est ce que le médiateur actuelle avait
compris en désignant parmi les délégués
du médiateur
un délégué chargé des français établis
hors de france
et cela à simplifier les choses et a
considérablement évolué et améliorer le
traitement des dossiers
or il se trouve qu'en l'assemblée
nationale a modifié le texte
article 28 non pas pour gêner les
français établis hors de france mais
pour essayer d'assurer une plus grande
territorialité des délégués
malheureusement en se limitant au
territoire national
ça nous enlève cette possibilité ce qui
explique pourquoi nous n'étions pas
intervenus en première lecture car le
texte du sénat nous paraissait
correspondre à ce qui était possible de
faire
cet amendement a donc pourvu tout
simplement de rétablir ce qui existe à
la satisfaction générale
bienvenue dans votre heure sur le 1
rectifier
qui prévoit la possibilité pour le
défenseur des droits de désigner des
délégués plus particulièrement chargé
des questions intéressant les français
établis hors de france
pas d'objection avis favorable je me
vois l'amendement a rectifié qui a deux
amis fera pied pour qui contre
l'amendement est adopté l'amendement 106
monsieur monsieur sueur merci monsieur
le président monsieur le ministre afin
de répondre à la nécessité d'
incarnation des droits de l'enfant dans
les territoires des délégués
territoriaux dédié exclusivement à la
défense et la promotion des droits de
l'enfant serait en vertu de notre
amendement désigné par le défenseur des
droits
sur proposition du défenseur des enfants
je me permets de signaler qu'il s'agit
d'abord une demande exprimée par la
défenseure des enfants avec son
dynamisme habituel mais que de surcroît
l'unicef soutient cette proposition et
qu'enfin il existe aujourd'hui un réseau
dans les différents départements de
correspondants du défenseur des enfants
il serait très dommageable que ce réseau
soit remise en cause c'est le sens de
cet amendement si monsieur n'en porter
organique de définir l'organisation
territoriale du défenseur des droits
ce sera à lui et à lui seul d'apprécier
dans quelle mesure et selon quelles
conditions il conviendra de créer un
réseau de correspondants territoriaux
il est toutefois entendu qu'il pourra
s'appuyer sur l'aide de ses adjoints et
des collèges pour prendre ses décisions
en la matière mais en l'espèce on ne
peut pas accepter la bande 906 donc avis
défavorable
je mets le moment 106 voix qui et pour
qui contre 106 n'est pas adopté deux
amendements discussion commune un
amendement qui est présenté par madame
garriaud-maylam amendement 139 rectifier
et merci monsieur le président j'ai
cosigné l'amendement qui a été présentée
par mon collègue christian cointat tout
à l'heure et qui a été accepté
je souhaitais simplement aller dans ma
formulation tout petit peu plus loin en
disant il désigne plutôt qu'il peut
désigner et en faisant encore référence
à ce un délégué qui s'occuperait plus
spécifiquement de la question de la
protection des enfants et des
déplacements illicites d'enfants
mais l'amendement de mon collègue
christian cointat qui d'ailleurs avait
aussi cosigné le mien ayant été adoptées
bien évidemment je retire mon amendement
et je fais confiance au gouvernement et
aux ministres en particulier pour que ce
délégué aux droits des français de
l'étranger soit bien spécifiquement
nommés
je vous remercie merci alors
l'amendement 139 actifs y est et retiré
l'amendement 23 n'est pas défendu ils
tombent nous en arrivons un amendement
53 rectifié qui est présenté par
jean-pierre sueur
merci monsieur le président oui cet
amendement à un objet qui est très clair
l'article 28 e prévoit que le défenseur
des droits désigne obligatoirement un ou
plusieurs délégués pour chaque
établissement pénitentiaire afin de
permettre aux personnes détenues de
bénéficier des dispositions du présent
projet de loi
il s'agit en fait d'une coordination
avec l'article 6 de la loi pénitentiaire
qui prévoit que le médiateur de la
république désigne un ou plusieurs
délégués pour chaque établissement
pénitentiaire
s'il convient d'adapter l'action
initialement entreprises par le
médiateur de la république auprès des
personnes détenues afin de leur
permettre de bénéficier dans les
meilleures conditions du droit reconnu à
toute personne par l'article 71 1 de la
course
tution de saisir le défenseur des droits
nous souhaitons préciser que cette
mission devrait être accomplie sans
préjudice des compétences du contrôleur
général des lieux de privation de
liberté et je précise que notre
amendement est d'autant plus justifiée
nous semble-t-il que puisque le sénat a
à juste titre décidé que le contrôleur
général des lieux de privation de
liberté ne serait pas englobé dans le
défenseur des droits dont il subsiste
ses prérogatives subsiste pleinement et
il est très important que l'on définisse
bien les compétences qui seront celles
du défenseur des droits
au travers des représentants qu'il
pourra nommer au sein des établissements
pénitentiaires par rapport aux
prérogatives du contrôleur général des
lieux de privation de liberté
autrement dit il ne faut pas que les
prérogatives du défenseur des droits
amoindrissent si peu que cela soit les
prérogatives qui sont aujourd'hui celles
du contrôleur des lieux de privation de
liberté
merci monsieur le rapporteur l'abord
résumé souligné un monsieur sûr que le
contrôleur général des lieux de
privation de liberté n'a jamais
considéré ni dans ses rapports ni lors
des auditions devant les commissions des
lois que l'intervention des délégués du
médiateur dans les prisons porter
atteinte ou risque est porté atteinte à
ses compétences
la précision qui est déposé dans cet
abonnement 53 rectifié n'apparaît donc
pas utile ni nécessaire et par
conséquent je demande le retrait ou s'il
n'y a pas de retrait avis défavorable
monsieur le ministre mais ma vie je mets
au voir l'amendement 50 points actifs y
es qui pour qui est contre
moi mon nid pas adopté je me vois
l'article 28 non son ensemble qui est
pour et qui est contre
il est adopté l'article 26 bis était
supprimée arctique 29 à ma maman 107
normalement il tombe droit
cr mais oui nous proposons et dans la
fidélité absolue à ce que nous défendons
depuis le début du débat monsieur le
président cela ne vous a pas échappé de
mentionner le défenseur des enfants dans
l'amendement 107 et d'indiquer dans
l'amendement 208 sauf si cela est
contraire à l'intérêt supérieur de
l'enfant amendements auquel tient
beaucoup
madame le défenseur des enfants est
aussi l'unicef bien j'irai je serais
tenté de considérer que le 100 cède par
cohérence est tombé mais j'irai on peut
si vous le souhaitez voter dessus on
peut considérer qu'il est tombé bien
alors on peut voter en revanche sur le
champ 8 après l'avis de la commission et
du ministre alors la loi du 6 mars 2000
instituant un défenseur des enfants
prévoit en son article premier que
lorsque le défenseur des enfants est
saisi directement par un enfant est peu
en informait ses représentants légaux
cette disposition a été reprise par
l'alinéa 2 de l'article 29
l'amendement précise que l'information
des représentants légaux ne doit pas
être contraire à l'intérêt supérieur de
l'enfant
cette précision va de soi d'ailleurs
personne n'a jamais prétendu que madame
dominique versini et avant elle adam
caire brisset ont méconnu l'intérêt
supérieur de l'enfant par une
information de mauvais aloi aux
représentants légaux alors même que la
loi du 6 mars 2000
ne prévoyez pas expressément que
l'information des représentants légaux
devait respecter l'intérêt supérieur de
l'enfant
le futur défenseur des droits aura
naturellement la même attitude prudente
sans qu'il soit nécessaire de modifier
la loi organique sur ce point donc je
demanderai leur retrait
sinon avis défavorable liste
maintenue retirer explications de vote
monsieur le président nous monsieur le
ministre nous maintenons cet amendement
car nous pensons que c'est un acte grave
que de ne pas informer les représentants
légaux de l'enfant il faut donc que cela
ne puisse être fait dans l'intérêt
supérieur de l'enfant
si tel est bien le cas donc nous
considérons que dans ces cas là dans les
cas où le fait de donner la
communication une communication aux
représentants légaux seraient eux
contraire au droit supérieur de l'enfant
eh bien il pourra une telle décision
pourra être prise naturellement et nous
pensons qu'il serait mieux que cela fut
inscrit dans la loi
toutefois je pense que le je crains que
le sénat ne suivent pas notre position
est à cet égard
même si notre position n'est pas suivi
je pense que la déclaration qui a été
faite par monsieur le rapporteur est
importante car elle permettra
d'interpréter la loi de telle manière
qu'il sera possible dans un certain
nombre de cas dans l'intérêt supérieur
de l'enfant de ne pas faire la
communication auprès de ses
représentants légaux
j'aimerais savoir d'ailleurs si à cet
égard monsieur le ministre à la même
interprétation que monsieur le
rapporteur puisque monsieur le ministre
a été laconique
non monsieur le monsieur le ministre je
pense que monsieur le rapporteur a dit
quelque chose d'important
il a dit que même si notre amendement
n'était pas adopté on pouvait entretenir
l'esprit est que la pratique pour être
celle là c'est important de savoir si le
gouvernement pense la même chose ce
n'est pas anodin la position du
gouvernement
merci monsieur monsieur le ministre a
bien sûr parce que j'aime bien mais je
veux simplement lui dire que j'utilise
les mots du vocabulaire dans le sens
qu'ils ont normalement et est dans le
sens de tous les jours lorsque je dis à
vie identique c'est que je partage ce
qu'a dit le rapporteur fait pas
simplement une formule bien jeux peuvent
être ou voit un amendement 108 qui est
pour
c'est contre l'amendement 108 n'est pas
un tgv l'article 29 dans son ensemble
qui est pour contre partie 29 et adopté
l'article 29 bis je n'ai pas
d'amendement je propose est considéré
comme adopté dans un marigot titre 5 sur
des dispositions finales le 30 glisse
n'est pas modifié le 31
je vous propose de le considérer comme
adoptée puisque pas d'amendement nous en
arrivons à l'article 32 alors article 32
je serais tenté de proposer à monsieur
se r et o regarder ceux de considérer
que par coordination et parcourir ans
ces deux amendements tombe puisqu'ils
sont en cohérence avec des dispositions
qui ont été refusés dans coeur voilà
souscrivez des mois mais c'était pas un
emprunt donc il y aura pas d'intérêt et
donc
donc c'est un rendement tombe mais en
revanche il faut ré chers collègues que
ceux qui souhaitent adopter l'article
le manifeste sans lendemain l'article 32
pour contre l'article 32 et adoptée à
l'article 33
nous avons un amendement quatre
amendements discussion commune alors
l'amendement 133 rectifié première est
la maman 77 reste mais les deux autres
amendements 55 et 130 de rectifier avec
le même désir de souscription
connaissent le même sort il tombe
est ce qu'il est et en coordination avec
des mesures qui n'ont pas été adoptés il
nous reste donc deux amendements et je
donne immédiatement la parole à
françoise laborde sur l'amendement 130
points rectifier merci monsieur le
président cet amendement a pour objet
d'avancer la date d'entrée en vigueur du
présent projet de loi organique en la
ramenant du premier jour du troisième au
deuxième mois suivant la publication de
la loi
il s'agit avant tout pour nous de
répondre à des considérations d'ordre
pratique et de limiter le retard déjà
considérable qu'a pris la mise en place
du défenseur des droits
le projet de loi organique prévue au
nouvel article 71 1 de la constitution
n'a été adopté par le conseil des
ministres que le 9 septembre 2009 il a
été adopté en première lecture au sénat
et à l'assemblée nationale les 3 juin
2010 et 18 janvier dernier entre temps
nous avons déjà dû proroger une première
fois le mandat du médiateur de la
république jusqu'au 31 mars prochain
date que le rapporteur souhaite
d'ailleurs une nouvelle fois reportée
par le projet de loi ordinaire prévoir
comme le fait l'article 33 une entrée en
vigueur de la loi organique le premier
jour du troisième mois suivant sa
publication revient de fait à repoussé à
l'été 2011 au mieux
soit près de trois ans après la révision
constitutionnelle
or restaurer une situation transit
n'est aucunement souhaitable dans le
domaine des libertés et de la défense
des droits vous en conviendrez
j'ajoute que cette situation est encore
complexifier par le fait que l'actuel
médiateur de la république
notre ancien collègue jean paul delevoye
a été élu il y à peu président du
conseil économique social et
environnemental sans viser directement
la personne nous sommes quelque peu
surpris qu'un cumul de fonctions aussi
incongru est été rendue possible même de
façon transitoire
il nous semble à tout le moins
juridiquement contestable de diriger
simultanément deux institutions
distinctes
tout comme cette situation incertaine
nous paraît dommageable à la
préservation des droits des administrés
qui s'adresse aux médiateurs en tout
état de cause le gouvernement a lui-même
souhaité lors de la discussion à
l'assemblée nationale
ramené ce délai d'entrée en vigueur à
deux mois nous souhaitons donc monsieur
le garde des sceaux que vous confirmer
aujourd'hui cette position en apportant
votre soutien à notre amendement
je vous remercie nous quittons
l'hémicycle du sénat nous reviendrons
bien entendu sur le défenseur des droits
dans notre journal de 19 heures
présentée ce soir par michel grossiord
merci de votre fidélité
il ya très bientôt sur public sénat
une dizaine des migrants qui viennent
pour certains d'être surpris et pour les
autres la village plus au sud en sommet
au sa source est une ville
lequel ils vont tenter de quitter la
somalie pour affronter l'océan et si
tout va bien gagner lié même là ils
seront en sécurité et il espère pouvoir
y travailler
nous sommes 128 à bord d'un bateau d'un
peu moins de 10 mètres au début du
voyage les passeurs m'interdisent de
sortir ma caméra ne sera possible de les
filmer pendant qu'ils m'appellent
passage